In this video, I will take you behind
the scenes of my risk management
protocols. From how I manage a prop firm
account to how I manage a competition
account to how I manage my personal
account. The prop firm risk geometry,
it's different from what they sell on
social media, okay? It's not about
sniper entry, it's not about high risk
to reward low win rate. This is the
blueprint for failure in a prop
environment, but is and all the way up
to [music] hedge fund risk management
protocols. Because while retail only
focus on technical analysis and
strategies, [music] professional only
holy grail is risk management. So, I'm
sure this video will help you to set up
your risk management and money
management better in your trading.
[music] Let's get started. Let's go over
the risk profile blueprints. Let's start
with the first one, and the first one
that we will cover today is the hedge
fund approach. What is the goal of the
hedge fund? The goal of the hedge fund
is maximize sustainable risk adjust
compounding over time. At the same time,
achieving the highest possible long-term
return for a given level of acceptable
risk and survivability. The rule should
be that you need to do this following
all the legal guidelines of the
regulators. But as you know, there are
thousands of cases where the hedge fund
maybe takes a fine of 200, 300 million,
but they make a profit for market
manipulation of 1, 2, 3 billion, okay?
So,
this one
should be like this, okay? But the top
five, the top 10 hedge fund in the world
have multiple cases related to this to
market manipulation, okay?
And let's go over the hedge fund
structure and risk framework. They are
diversified, okay? They are risk aware,
and they point at asymmetric return
because they want the minimum amount of
risk and the potential upside, okay?
Related to this. So, they start from the
risk protocol. They don't start from the
raw return protocol, for example, like
competition environment, okay?
And let's go over how hedge fund
diversify. They diversify by strategy.
You can have global macro, you can have
event driven, you can have quantitative,
you can have trend following, you can
have a blend of these, you can have a
multi-strategy, you can have arbitrage,
you can have HFT. There are thousands of
strategies that you can implement in an
hedge fund. And they pointed having
multiple of them to have the best
possible diversification. Recently, we
saw how much this one is important when
we saw the the conflict in the Middle
East, no? Because if you were completely
exposed, let's say, for example, you are
an hedge fund that is exposed in the
financial markets of the UAE, you would
have taken a huge hit recently. But they
are they have a diversified global
exposure. So, they pointed minimizing
this. Also, the legal structure we will
not over go over the legal structure,
but they are divided in the portfolio
management side. They have a research
and analytics. They have operations in
the back office. They they trading the
execution side is divided. They have um
department that are for risk profiling.
So, it's all separated, okay? They have
auditors, they have their own
infrastructure to execute, they have the
legal side. So, it's it's a whole
corporate entity, okay? It's not a
strategy that you put there and you open
the hedge fund. It's it's a different
entity. And this will be my dream
because this excite me so much. Right
now, I only managed to be in the
research and analytics side for the
hedge fund. I still didn't manage to
open mine, and I hope in 2027 I 2027
2028 I will manage to do it. Now, going
on, we can see, for example, the 2025
performance of multiple hedge fund using
aggregated strategy, okay? They can use
quant macro, they can use CTA, they can
use credit, they can use event driven,
they can use convertible, volatility,
discretionary macro, all of them. And
you can see the index performance. And
here comes the usual retail trader,
okay? The usual retail trader see this,
they only watch the performance, the raw
return, okay? Like they do in the
competition, and they see, "Oh, you did
20% with MCA world, you did 17.5%
in the S&P 500. So, it's useless all the
infrastructure for this year 2025 of the
hedge fund is not like this." And they
will explain you why. Because the goal
of the hedge fund is not to optimize for
maximum return. The goal of the hedge
fund is to optimize for maximum risk,
okay? So, they want to take the minimum
possible amount of risk, and they put a
maximum on it, okay? And they see how
much they can do with this maximum
amount of risk. Maybe to make this 20%
2025, they had a maximum drawdown during
Trump tariff, for example, of 30%, of
20, of 18. And maybe to do this 14%,
they had a maximum drawdown of 5% on the
account. So, you can understand that
when you introduce the concept of
risk-adjust return, everything change.
And if you optimize for
maximum performance, so raw return, you
are
focusing yourself on only one matrix of
the trading world. Now,
going on,
how what would you think about this,
okay? In 1988 and 1989, the Medallion
Fund, so one should know it, did 15%,
okay? And 1%. So, if Jim Simons was
there online, okay, talking
everywhere about his model or about his
infrastructure and about his enthusiasm
of starting this quantitative journey,
he would have been attacked. You see,
"Look, you cannot even beat
the S&P 500 return, okay? You did 1%
here and 15% here." And this is the
reason why
professionals often laugh
at the comments of retail traders, no?
Because they don't understand that maybe
he had this with 10 times less risk,
okay? And in trading you can have a
negative week, you can have a negative
month, and in the worst case you can
also have a negative full year, okay?
Specifically, if you have something that
is called the black swan, something
unpredictable, let's take for example
what happened in the UAE now, okay? On
the real estate side, there was a black
swan, okay? You had a flash crash of the
prices on the value of real estate,
already recovered, but you had something
like this. And if you were exposed in
geopolitical condition on this field,
you would have experienced something
that it's not measurable in the in
sample. So, you can test everything, you
can make all the evaluation, but you
could have not predicted something like
this, okay?
So, the concept of a return they
correlated from the market and the risk
adjusted return. The outline of
Medallion, now let's see how they
behave. As you can see, if you take
only this portion, okay? You will think,
no, doesn't make sense for me to invest
in the Medallion fund. But then you go
in the next year and you see the S&P 500
close negative, okay? And they close
57%, okay? When the S&P 500 close 26,
they close 43, okay? And then the
momentum and the compounding also start
to kick in. What you want to do with the
hedge fund is minimize this, okay? For
an investor to have three negative year,
okay? On the S&P 500 return will be a
disaster, okay? In 2008, when the market
did minus 46%, they did a 92.5%,
okay? And this is important. You don't
need to You don't need to take only the
isolated return. You need to take the
risk adjusted return to related to it,
okay?
For example, this
is the project that is only B2B, okay?
Edge Forge in mainland Abu Dhabi that
I'm using to provide research to the
hedge fund, okay? So, I'm in this side
here. I don't talk about this on the
social media, but I'm also active, okay?
In the hedge fund perspective. Not
operational. To build a structure like
this, I think it will take me still one
or two years, and I will need to do an
audit out of sample of each model I
trade independently if I wants to
implement here, and also the liquidity
capabilities of the model. This is
something that no retail will think
about, but every model have a maximum
liquidity capability, okay? You cannot
put billions in a scalping model, okay?
You will take too much slippage, and the
model will not be profitable. So, you
need also to do a lot of measurements
that neither in the retail war are
completely ignored, okay? Now, let's go
on the prop risk model breakdown. The
goal here is high pass rate and high
probability of payout. Now, the prop
firm risk geometry survival blueprint
it's different from what they sell on
social media, okay? It's not about
sniper entry, it's not about high risk
to reward low win rate. This is the
blueprint for failure in a prop
environment, but is understanding the
risk geometry based on the rules of the
prop firm, okay? And here I did some
infographics to explain why high win
rate risk geometry is the best for prop
firm because the goal here is to
optimize for the variance of the
results, okay? So, you don't want to
have a huge amount of profit, but
variable. Maybe this strategy in the
month after does like this. So, does a
crazy amount of profit, but you have a
higher probability of getting
consecutive losses, and over a large
number of sample this one goes way
higher because the blacks one is always
there, and maybe this strategy is
profitable, but the variation needs to
high of burning the account. What you
have here the high win rate geometry, is
going on models that have win rate above
60-70%
and are capable of getting you a higher
probability of pass rate, a lower risk
of ruin, and a lower max drawdown. And
you will think, "Oh, but it takes me
more time to pass the prop firm because
I cannot take the sniper one to 10 that
happens one times every week." Yes, I
agree with you, but maybe in the attempt
to take that sniper, you go in the low
variance and you lose, okay? You lose
your account. Remember that is not a
personal account. You cannot manage as a
personal account. And here I show some
tests, two paths, two probabilities, and
you can see that both the strategy are
profitable. So, you can have a strategy
that goes around this line, okay? Or
around this line, around this line, but
you have a higher variance. Why? Because
you could incur a large amount of
drawdown. This one is a simulation on
only 3 months, okay? Not on the long
term for scalping. So, these are both
valuable strategy, but this one have a
lower cone of probabilities, okay?
So, the amount that you will incur, a
streak of stop loss that will make you
waste the money for the prop firm, is
lower. And that's the reason I strongly
analyze that from a probability
perspective, the best approach that you
can have is the low variance risk
geometry. So, having high win rate,
okay? Moderate risk per trade and going
for moderate risk reward, one to one,
even one to 0.75,
maximum one to 1.5. This is the best for
prop firm survival, okay? Specifically
in the pass rate. And here I gave you a
summary of the optimal low variance
path, okay? And the high variance path,
okay? They can make way more profit than
this, okay? But they can be
inconsistent, so maybe you have a period
like this and then you have three
amazing months. But in the period like
this, you burn the prop firm, okay? So,
you need to understand that this needs
to be treated following the game theory,
okay? You need to understand the goal,
you need to understand the rule. I
strongly think that prop firm trading is
way different from real trading, okay?
Because you are not trading the real
market, you are trading the rules that
another entity put on you. So, you are
trading a synthetic market.
Here is the prop firm risk geometry
across phases, okay? You can see that on
the evaluation phase, the best one is
the low variance zone, okay? And on the
funded phase, you need to optimize for
high outcome, because you want to get a
payout, okay? The goal here is to get a
payout, and there is a a thing that no
one consider here, okay? And I will
share one experience about my life.
Some years ago, there was one prop firm
in the CFD space. I will not make the
name, that was based in Canada, okay?
And I requested from them
more than $50,000 in one payout, okay?
When I received in the bank account that
payout, this payout got flagged for
review. Why? Because the prop was having
problems with the regulator. So, you
also needs to input the probability
that the prop firm have way more risk
than a brokerage, okay? So, compounding
on the prop and keeping all the money on
the prop is not the best option, okay?
The best option is to withdraw as much
as you can and put in your personal
account. Here I did some projection of
one approach that I've made. This one I
think was the trading pit. I traded a
live the prop firm some years ago with
the community
using the order flow approach, and I
tried to go on the side
of the low variance part. This one I use
a risk reward that it's even too high,
but I had a really high win rate on this
one. It was a
a phase where the regime of the market
was completely directional and I did
some stress test to pass the prop firm.
And after a lot of test and also a lot
of review on the community, I noticed
that the high win rate model with low
variance and with low risk to reward is
the best one probability of passing it,
okay? Then you can go on this side on
aggressive optimization and yes, if you
have a high probability model, you could
try to optimize for the maximum amount
of withdrawal. But then you you need to
consider also the rules about the prop,
okay? because some some prop have
consistency rules. Now, let's go in the
CME Group equity cap breakdown. The goal
here is to build equity fast with
minimum downside possible, extremely
limited time and symmetric incentives,
okay?
The rules, single account, so you cannot
test on sequential real account, no
test, okay? And here you have an
extremely limited time. So, in the
equity cup, the CME Group, for those who
don't know, the CME Group is the biggest
exchange in the world and they organize
a cup one time per year, okay? One time
I decided to participate because
their platform is really amazing, okay?
And what I did here is I had only one
approach, so I didn't have time to test
regime and I didn't even have the
possibility to test the live market
environment. So, what I did, I used the
best model that I have
and the best model that I have is this
one.
Is the order flow high win rate scalping
low variance, the one that you saw me
using in all the podcast in the world
where I traded live or in the live
trading session, okay? And the goal here
is to unlock margin to go heavier. So,
as you can see here,
the goal is to keep the drawdown as low
as possible because the time is limited,
so if you go in drawdown, you have even
less margin. So,
it's almost guaranteed that you will not
be in the top percentile of the
competition, okay?
And I got a positive drift in the
beginning, okay? I was positioned in the
top 0.7, 0.6%, I don't remember, 0.6%,
okay? And the risk-reward payoff is
amazing. So, everyone that will see
this, okay, will say, "Okay, you did 50,
60 execution, you had a net profit of
54.6%,
a maximum drawdown 0.42, okay? You are
better than funds." No, no, no, no, no.
First of all,
the risk protocol and approach that got
used here, it's aggressive. This
protocol here, everyone will be crazy to
apply this protocol in a net fund, okay?
Second of all, okay, you are approaching
here in a positive drift. So,
in this case here, probably, I took
this, okay? I took this positive. If you
continue with this risk, when you take
the negative, okay? Maybe you will
approach a drawdown that is 10 times
this. It's still acceptable, huh? Still
acceptable. But maybe for a certain prop
firm that allocate a maximum risk per
model, not prop firm, sorry, hedge fund,
a maximum risk per model is not
acceptable, okay? Here are all the
execution that I took in the cup. And as
you can see, okay, you have the
execution compounding on the heavy side
when I release margin, okay? The more I
was releasing margin, the more I was
getting aggressive, okay?
And on this one, also, what you can see
is that the incentive, okay, is to
optimize not only for performance, but
to optimize also for maximum drawdown,
because the leaderboard and the
competition is composed that everyone,
okay, can see the maximum profit and the
max drawdown of the user, okay? So, it's
a completely different competition
environment here. And also, you cannot
test, you don't have time to test the
regime and to test sequential. You need
to go there with the most the model that
you are the most confident and you have
one opportunity. Okay? Now, let's go on
the World Trading Cup competition. Okay?
The goal, terminal rank position, convex
upside, and the symmetric incentive,
limited time. Why terminal rank
position? Because in this cup here, and
you can see from the composition of the
leaderboard, the final goal is the
percentage. Okay? So, the approach is
totally different from personal account,
okay? Also from prop firm account, and
from the hedge fund approach. Okay? And
I explain this because I request I see I
receive I receive a lot of requests
related to, "But why if you can do 500%?
Okay? You don't do this in an hedge fund
that you don't manage capital." Guys,
you don't understand the goal of the
competition. The goal of the competition
is not optimized for risk of ruin. It's
not optimized for maximum drawdown. It's
optimized, okay? For terminal rank
positioning. And in the game theory, we
will go over this, okay? You need to
understand, first of all, the goal of
what you are doing is different from
personal, is different from hedge fund,
is different from prop firm, is
different from active management
certificate, is different on investment,
it's completely different on everything.
And you need to understand this. So,
the rules. You don't need to use
simultaneous account to avoid edging.
For example, one account long or one
account short that can influence the
performance or illegal trading tactics.
For example, I don't know, arbitrage or
something like this. And the sequential
account are allowed. So, you are allowed
to test multiple models and strategy. Of
course, in a short-term competition, you
will be stupid, okay? To test too many
strategy because you don't have the
time. So, you don't have the time to
appear in the leaderboard then.
And from a game theory perspective, this
completely change the optimal
equilibrium strategy. So, you need to
take controlled enough controlled
variance to maximize profitability of
top percentile outcome at the same time
minimizing the probability of total
elimination.
Nash equilibrium implies that the
optimal strategy depends on how other
competitors are expected to behave under
the same incentives, okay? Most
participants deploy aggression too
early. If you open the leaderboard in
the beginning is 200% 100% and then they
disappear, okay? Because they optimize
for immediate ranking instead of
long-term positioning, okay? Early
uncontrolled aggression increase the
variance
before you have enough information,
first of all, about the regime of the
market. So, if the market is compressing
like it was last week, okay? Or if the
market is expanding under the peace
treaty of Trump and Iran, you need to
use completely different models, okay?
And the leaderboard structure, okay,
here is known, okay? So, at the second
third month, you know what's your goal.
And if your goal is to beat, for
example, hide to my friend Nazri Khan
that did that 120%,
you cannot use a conservative approach.
You will not even appear in the
leaderboard. So, you need to input the
maximum amount of aggression in the late
stage. But before you need to know who
is your competitor. Accounting for World
Trading Cup commission and real
execution cost prevent false positive
expectancy model. For example, I
deployed model, I tried model in the
World Trading Cup that comes from the
quant, okay? Uh for example, the
automated and you can see that with the
markup on execution, okay, and the
slippage, they are making profit but
never enough to win this kind of
competition, okay? So, the first one
framework optimize, information
acquisition, validation, and then
asymmetric payoff deployment last. This
is the 3 months competition structure.
This is the blueprint, okay, for this
kind of competition. Any competition
environment can have a different. The
phase one
is regime detection and testing out of
sample. So, you have strategy that are
profitable on the long term. But
remember that here you have only 3
months. So, you need to test in a live
market environment. So, in the cap,
okay, three strategy in my case I I
used. One account that trend following
strategy I tested. One account that has
the mean reverting and one account I
tested the volatility breakout, okay?
And I have a matrix of the one that is
sustainable to scale risk, okay? If I
see that the regime is compressing,
trend following strategy, even if it's
profitable on the long term, in this
phase here will not give me a
leaderboard positioning. So, this one is
discarded. If the market is rewarding
the compression, okay, and I see in the
first month, okay, here, I use this one,
okay?
The second month is validation and
moderate risk. So,
what you need to do? You won this first
phase test, okay? The mean reverting
strategy, perfect. So, you open the
account, okay, and you deploy risk on
the mean reverting strategy. And you
say, "Oh, but you lost 1 month for
testing." No, you didn't lost 1 month
because first of all, now you have
information about who is your enemy, the
leaderboard. And second of all, you have
the perfect model for the regime, okay?
Now, you can test also this one, okay,
in a simulation environment. But in a
simulation environment, you will not
have the exact commission and you will
not have the ex- the exact live
slippage. And as you know, for models
that have, like the one that I use,
500-600
execution per quarter, the slippage and
commission are a huge part of it, okay?
So, in the second part, use the model,
you validate it, okay, and you start to
scale.
You start to scale using this this risk
protocol.
In the third phase is when you do
convexity exploitation, okay? So, you
want to be in the first slot, second
slot, third slot. Usually, they are
above
50 to 150%, okay? So, it's a huge
performance for 3 months. So, you need
to deploy maximum aggression on this.
And here is when the maximum amount of
execution is concentrated. In the second
half of the middle month and the third
month is where I make 3-400 trades. I
stay there 6 hours per day scalping with
the model that I choose. And this is
what gave me
then the results, okay? If I go on the
1-year competition,
it's possible that I will do it, okay? I
will use the quarter for testing, so
okay? So, I will open an account with
trend following test, mean reverting,
volatility, and I will choose the
winner, okay? To then approach
extreme risk and deploying capital in
this, okay? So, I will
probably make in 9 months the total that
I make in 12 months of competition,
okay? So, I will make probably more than
2,000 execution. And it's really
important that you make this test
properly because if you don't account
for commission and you do this test in
simulation, not real account, if you
don't put the correct slippage, a
profitable strategy can become an
unprofitable strategy, okay? This is the
validation of it. I already published
this. This is the podium account
reconstruction performance. The
cumulative month is the 68 and 22%,
uh
22% maximum drawdown. We had 89.5%, 158%
cumulative. Uh this one went losing,
yeah? As you can see, even if you make
all the possible test, here,
I lost
for
2 weeks, okay? Not that but I was in
drawdown for the first week and I
recovered for the second, too. Okay. And
then I deployed aggression in the late
phase. Was not enough to win. This
performance for an edge fund that it's
it's amazing. Okay. And this is why you
cannot compare an edge fund with a
competition or an edge fund with a
personal account. Okay?
And for example, I give you the
breakdown of the first one. The
consideration that I make is someone
considered to join swing trading have is
too slow. You have for the quarterly
competition, you don't have enough
sample. If you want to win, you should
take a huge amount of risk in one or two
position.
And from my point of view, winning a
World Cup with three, four, five
position,
it's not a sample validation that will
give you any kind of satisfaction. Okay?
Because it can also be luck.
And so it's not enough sample. This one
is discarded and also
the small account. So if you enter with
2,500, you pay more commission. Okay?
Because you need to open micro and your
edge will will pay a huge amount of
commission. It will be deployed. Okay?
It will Sorry, it will not survive the
execution of 300, 400, 500 trades. Okay?
This is all stuff that I tested. I
understood. No. If you want to optimize
for optimal rank positioning, you will
never survive with this. So the regime
test, for example, I give you the
example of the first one. The mean
reverting bad performance. The market
was directional. Okay? The account two,
trend following. Amazing performance
directional market. This is the first
choice. This is the second choice. This
is the third choice. Okay? This one is
discarded. This one is discarded. This
is the model that is telling me you can
deploy risk. Okay? Perfect. I open the
account that I that will go to podium.
Okay? Where I deploy risk. And on this
one, I go aggressively trend following
scalping. Okay? 500, 600 in one quarter,
if I'm not wrong, 650 execution. Of
course, these results are not typical.
This doesn't mean that if you use this
approach, you will have the same results
and all the disclaimer. Now, let's go on
the personal account. What's the goal on
the personal account? Risk adjust
return, psychological stability, and
long-term compounding. Only if moderate
risk tolerance, you can compound profit,
okay? So, if you are not super
conservative, but you are moderate like
me, and you have a month where you make
an exceptional performance, I don't
know, six figures in profit, you could
use part of this profit to input
additional risk in the next sample,
maybe the triple A sample, okay? This is
of course a moderate approach, it's not
a conservative approach. You also need
to have multiple account and multiple
brokerage on the personal account, and I
explain you why. I had a trauma, I don't
know how many of you remember with FTX,
okay? I was ranking in the leaderboard
of FTX, I was an extremely active crypto
scalper, and in this case, FTX decided
to shut down everything. So, I tried to
access to the portal, there is no
access, okay? This created for me a
trauma on the single brokerage use for
the field. So, if I do crypto now, I
don't use only one broker, okay? If I do
futures, I have four, five, six broker,
okay? Maybe one is perfect for more
scalping, one is more perfect for
investment, okay? But I use multiple of
them, and they needs to have insurance.
You need to isolate tail risk, okay?
Unpredictable situation like the the
failure of the brokerage, the default.
This can happen, guys, okay? So, if you
keep everything in one, maybe you have
an extremely accurate risk management in
your personal account, then something
happen and you lose everything, okay?
So, the diversification is not with only
models and account, but it's also with
multiple brokerage and models, okay?
Discretionary, algo, short-term,
long-term. For example, I have one
portfolio that is not managed by me, but
it's managed by one person that it's
paid by me to do exactly this, and it's
the options one portfolio with
algorithmic strategy on the option side,
okay? I have my discretionary models,
and I have also an algo model, one model
that
Luca validated on the multi-charts and
also we receive an audit from a market
maker
that generated 30 million in profit,
Matteo.
He did an audit, no, of the model
because I show the the model logic on
YouTube for free, the IVB model, and he
validated if the volume was actually
contributing to improve the model, okay?
He did a video about it and he also
texts me to give me to say, "Look, it's
it looks really amazing, okay?" And so,
if you need to have multiple models,
okay, you need also to diversify with
multiple platforms and with multiple
brokerage account, okay? And in this
case, the personal account strategy, I
know I'm moderate, but if you want to be
really conservative, it should be 1.25%,
0.5% per trade, okay? And I know that
now the retail trading world will say,
"But you are crazy." But it's I I will
never live with 1,000 if I put this
risk. The problem is not the risk that
I'm saying. The problem is the
conception in the industry where you can
live out of trading with $500, $1,000
because this is what your mentor told,
okay? And the fact that he put a photo
with a Lamborghini convinced you that
you can live, okay, with $500. If this
was possible, okay, if living with this
small amount was possible, okay, I will
be billionaire with the amount that I
trade, okay? But it's not like this
because the risk profiling is extremely
important specifically for survival
rate. If you risk, for example, I saw
some people risking 5%, okay? If you
incur in a streak of a drawdown, you
will destroy. And as you see, look at
the how the pyramid is inverted.
The pyramid of risk is the opposite of
the competition. First point is the
ability, okay? Second point is risk
management, risk adjusted return, and in
the end the real return. Here,
okay,
the goal
terminal rank positioning. So, or
return. That's the reason it's called a
competition. Even, okay,
on this, I think this one was the best
experience that I've ever had of stress,
okay? Because you are competing against
people that input a huge amount of risk,
like big props to to Nasri Khan, is a
footprint scalper, and you need to push
yourself, even if you are I will be
happy already with the performance that
I did the first 2 weeks, okay? But no,
if you want to be in the leaderboard,
you need to step it on the gas. And you
need, of course, to have a plan, okay, a
tolerance of risk. You need to have an
execution model that should be also
automated in terms of blocking the
maximum risk per day, the maximum risk
per week, and you need to track. If
there is no measurement, there is no
improvement in trading, okay? And then
there is all the adaptation and
optimization part that quant traders are
well aware of, but retail traders never
do. So, if, for example, I give you an
example, no? On this strategy, the IVB,
that is based on the fact that the
nature of the US equities have
predictable behavior during the opening,
okay? And that the bottom of the first
30 minutes is giving a lot of value in
the direction of the day, can be
improved. For example, can be improved
with option flow, and this is the study
that I'm doing. But a lot of people are
not happy, okay? They they they don't
want to do this, okay? They are happy
with what they have at the moment. So,
what they do is just till it's
profitable, I will not implement new
concepts, okay? And this is the reason
then the strategy break. On the
investment side, okay, I have multiple
models. One of the models is the earning
surprise that the riff portfolio, this
is a well-documented
situation that is post earnings drift,
okay? Surprise, of course, when there is
a a mismatch between the expectation and
the surprise. They use a model for this.
I use
uh blockchain intelligence. This is one
model that I created for the long-term
investment to create an accumulation
plan on Bitcoin that is smart, that is
based on this mathematical constraint
and infrastructure. So, it takes into
account the miner. Also, I never talk
about crypto in this channel. Please let
me know if you would like me to make a
master class about the blockchain
intelligence model on the long term for
free, okay? And uh then I do a lot of
data research, okay? So, I tried to see
who which kind of holders and how much
it's heavy these holders is buying
certain stocks. If it's in the
congressman, so it's a politician. If
it's um uh for example, an hedge fund
that can deploy a huge amount of capital
like BlackRock. They have always the
best analysis team. And these data are
public, are completely legal, okay? It's
published from the government. So, if
you have enough time and you want to do
research, this one it's an amazing way
to build a stock portfolio, okay? And
this is the five point of the risk
protocol that I use in all environment
of trading. I hope you enjoyed it. Let
me know in the comment if you want more
video like this. And if you would like
to give me a breakdown of the long-term
model for free in the YouTube channel.
Have a great day. If you enjoyed this
video, leave a like and a comment, and
let me know which risk protocol works
best for you.